Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. A wise man once said, a true history of the world is a history of great conversations in elegant rooms. Sounds like the rest is history. Those are the words of the dwarf from Game of Thrones, Tyrion Lannister, that great historian. And that's our subject this week, Game of Thrones.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及我们备受欢迎的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。智者曾经说过，一部真正的世界史，就是优雅房间里伟大对话的历史。听起来就像是《历史的余烬》。这是《权力的游戏》中那个侏儒——伟大的历史学家提利昂·兰尼斯特（Tyrion Lannister）的话。这也是我们这周的主题：《权力的游戏》。
Tom Holland, are you a fan of the Sex and Sandals and Swords hit? I am, and I'm proud to say that I was an early adopter because I read the early books before the TV show started. And I've got to say that it was one of the great reading experiences of my life. Wow, that's a good claim. Yeah, I got the first book, devoured it pretty much in a day, queued up early to get to the bookshop the next day to get the second one. I thought they were really great. And I thought they, I kind of quite enjoyed the TV series as well, but I thought that the book was brilliant.
汤姆·霍兰，你是这部红极一时的“性、沙滩与宝剑”剧集的粉丝吗？我是，而且我很自豪地说，我是个早期的拥趸，因为在电视剧开播之前我就读过原著。我必须说，这是我人生中最棒的阅读体验之一。哇，这评价可真高。对，我买到第一本书后，几乎一天之内就狼吞虎咽地读完了，第二天还起了个大早排队去书店买第二本。我觉得它们真的太棒了。而且我觉得，呃，我也挺喜欢这部电视剧的，但我觉得原著小说简直绝了。
So had you got all the way through before you started the TV series? Had you got to the, as far as you could get? Yeah, I got as far as I could. And the other link that I have with game of thrones is that um i once got sojourner mormont um lbw oh in glenn in glenn yeah i'm aware that for people who know nothing about cricket and haven't read game of thrones that will mean absolutely nothing of all our facts that, that's the most obscure. That's the best, isn't it? Which I guess kind of highlights the way in which this is an episode that we risk annoying two constituencies. And one of them, obviously,
所以你在看电视剧之前，就已经把书全都读完了吗？你读到了当时能读到的进度？对，我读到了我能读到的最新进展。我和《权力的游戏》的另一个缘分是，嗯，我曾经在格伦（Glenn）让乔尔·莫尔蒙（Jorah Mormont）被判“脚踢球犯规”（LBW，前译：保龄球判决）哦，在格伦，在格伦，对。我深知对于那些对板球一无所知、又没看过《权力的游戏》的人来说，这简直毫无意义。在我们所有的趣事中，这绝对是最晦涩难懂的一个。这才是最棒的，不是吗？我想这某种程度上也凸显了这一期节目的风险——我们可能会惹恼两个阵营。其中一个阵营，显而易见，
is people who know everything about Game of Thrones. Because it's a while since I've watched it. I'm not absolutely on top of every last detail. But also, of course, there may be people listening who've never read the books, who've never seen the TV show, maybe wondering why on a history podcast we're talking about a work of fiction. And I think that the reason for doing it is focused by a question from David Haskier, who asks, how do you feel about the likely fact that the TV series has shaped popular perception about the medieval period more than popular historical TV or books. I mean, I'd go further and say that nothing in the 21st century has done more to shape the way that a broader range of people now think about the past than Game of Thrones. That's bigger more than Gladiator. I mean, Gladiator is huge. Much more, much more. Wow. Yeah.
就是那些对《权力的游戏》无所不知的人。因为我已经有一段时间没看过了。我不可能对每一个细节都绝对了如指掌。但当然了，听众里也可能有人从未读过原著，从未看过电视剧，甚至可能会纳闷，为什么我们要在历史播客里讨论一部虚构作品。我觉得我们之所以这么做，是因为大卫·哈斯基尔（David Haskier）的一个提问激发了灵感，他问：“对于电视剧对中世纪大众认知的塑造，可能已经超过了大众历史电视或书籍这一事实，你们怎么看？”我的意思是，我要说得更进一步：在21世纪，没有任何东西比《权力的游戏》更能塑造广大民众对过去的看法了。这比《角斗士》影响还要深远。我的意思是，《角斗士》的影响力已经够大了。大得多，大得多。哇。对。
Because it was such a phenomenon. And although it's fantasy, the whole thing about it is that it's rooted in kind of various historical episodes, various historical periods all mixed together. And I think it's hugely influential on how people see the past. It's in a continuum, though, isn't it, Tom? I mean, Lord of the Rings, Walter Scott, Ivanhoe, sort of Victorian historical evocations of the Middle Ages. I mean, Game of Thrones, isn't it just the latest iteration of these ways that that we over the past centuries have have understood i think i guess particularly the medieval past but dominic for the benefit of those who have never read or seen game of thrones here's your start of a tale it's like kind of radio four panel show can you give the plot of game of thrones in what a minute two minutes well i did the french revolution in about 90 seconds so game of thrones is a bit more complex isn't it so for people so this is basically for people who haven't
因为它曾是一种社会现象。尽管它是奇幻作品，但整部作品的核心在于，它植根于各种历史事件和被融为一体的不同历史时期。我认为它对人们如何看待过去有着巨大的影响力。不过，它也是一脉相承的，对吧，汤姆？我的意思是，《指环王》、沃尔特·司各特（Walter Scott）、《艾凡赫》（Ivanhoe）、维多利亚时代对中世纪的历史唤起……我的意思是，《权力的游戏》，它不就是过去几个世纪以来我们理解——我猜尤其是中世纪过去——的那些方式的最新演变吗？不过，多米尼克，为了那些从未读过或看过《权力的游戏》的人，请给我们讲讲故事的开端——这听起来有点像BBC第四台的小组访谈节目——你能在一分钟或两分钟内概括一下《权力的游戏》的剧情吗？好吧，我用大约90秒讲完了法国大革命，所以《权力的游戏》要复杂一些，对吧？所以，对于那些……这基本上是为那些没有
haven't seen it already um because everybody else will be appalled by my gross oversimplifications as no doubt they always are um so basically game of thrones i think is two things one it's a story set in the sort of vaguely middle ages-ish time in this continent called Westeros, which is near the top of the continent. There's a huge wall, which is basically Hadrian's Wall. And on the other side, there's these snowy wastes. And there have always been stories and rumours about some terrible menace that's going to come
还没看过的人准备的，嗯，因为其他人都会对我的严重过度概括感到震惊，就像他们平时毫无疑问会做的那样。嗯，所以基本上，《权力的游戏》我认为包含两部分：第一，它的故事背景设定在威斯特洛（Westeros）这块大陆上一个隐约类似中世纪的时期，这个大陆位于大陆的北部边缘。那里有一堵巨大的墙，基本上就是哈德良长城（Hadrian's Wall）。而在墙的另一边，是白雪皑皑的荒原。一直以来都有关于某种可怕威胁的传说和流言，说它会穿过
through the snowy wastes across the wall. And these are the White Walkers. These are kind of zombies. And the show starts with the realisation that basically the zombies are coming. And this is looming over the whole story. So that's one aspect of it. So you know there's this kind of apocalyptic confrontation coming.
白雪皑皑的荒原，跨过长城。这些就是异鬼（White Walkers）。它们有点像僵尸。剧集开场就意识到，基本上僵尸要来了。这笼罩着整个故事。所以这是其中的一个方面。你知道，将会有一场末日般的对决。
But then most of the narrative is actually about the fight for supremacy in what are called the Seven Kingdoms. So there's the Iron Throne, which is the sort of, you know, the throne, obviously. And there is a series of kind of Wars of the Roses-style shenanigans and sort of soap opera machinations as these different families, who are clearly modelled on different families from medieval history, are fighting for control. And at the beginning, you're invited i mean the the
但随后，大部分叙事实际上都是关于争夺被称为“七大王国”的统治权的斗争。这里有铁王座（Iron Throne），也就是那种，你知道的，理所当然的王座。随之而来的是一系列类似于《玫瑰战争》（Wars of the Roses）的阴谋诡计，以及肥皂剧式的权谋斗争，不同的家族——它们显然是以中世纪历史上的不同家族为原型——为了争夺控制权而战。而在一开始，你会受邀去——
distinctive thing about game of thrones because some people will be thinking that doesn't sound very distinctive at all but the distinctive thing about it i suppose is that at the very beginning you're invited to empathize with one particular family from the north of the continent and it's very clear that they are going to be your sort of eyes into this world. And then the tables are turned by the end of the first book or the first series. And you realize that actually a lot of them are going to start getting killed off. And you start to realize that this whole enterprise has a sensibility that you don't expect, that nothing can be taken for granted, and the characters that you have invested in are going to be killed off really horribly. And then it's sort of, there's just twist part upon twist.
《权力的游戏》最与众不同之处在于——有些人可能会觉得这听起来一点也不独特——但我认为它的独特之处在于，在一开始，你会受邀去对大陆北部的某一个特定家族产生共情，很显然，他们将成为你观察这个世界的视角。然而，到了第一本书或第一季结束时，局势却来了个一百八十度大转弯。你会意识到，实际上他们中的许多人将开始被杀死。你会开始意识到，整个作品有一种你意想不到的基调：没有什么事是理所当然的，你所投入感情的角色将会以极其残酷的方式被杀死。然后，剧情简直是反转再反转。
And yet all the time, you know, the zombies are coming, which gives it this sort of other dimension. And then, of course, there is one third dimension, which a lot of people loved, which is the fact that it has dragons. And dragons are these mythical creatures that are kind of the ultimate weapon that people don't believe exist anymore.
然而与此同时，你知道，僵尸正在逼近，这赋予了它某种额外的维度。然后，当然还有第三个维度，许多人都为之着迷，那就是它有龙。龙是这种神话生物，是人们认为已经不复存在的终极武器。
And they're going to come back and change the dynamic of the entire show. And that's basically Game of Thrones. Brilliant. Absolutely brilliant. And to fix on the dragons, I've got a friend who refuses point blank to have any dealings with anything that has dragons. Wow. Just like the hobbits.
它们将会卷土重来，改变整个剧集的格局。这就是《权力的游戏》的基本情况。太棒了。绝对太棒了。就拿龙来说吧，我有个朋友，他斩钉截铁地拒绝接触任何跟龙有关的东西。哇。就像对待霍比特人那样？
No, no. Faggner's Ring. Yeah, all of it. Hates it. Dragons for him for him are the absolute mark he's not going to touch it so you mentioned both zombies and dragons chinese new year neither yeah no but they're different aren't they i think he's talking about the medieval western okay zombies and dragons immediately mark it out as the kind of thing that that is not straight historical fiction yeah so perhaps we could i mean let's look at both of them so so there's a question from ghost of film past where did the idea of dragons originate from and one answer that is obviously it's very clear isn't it it's it's coming from medieval literature yeah
不，不。瓦格纳的《指环》（Ring）。对，所有的全都不看。恨透了。对克来说，龙是绝对的红线，他碰都不会碰。所以你刚才提到了僵尸和龙……中国新年？这两个都不是。对，但它们是不一样的，对吧？我觉得他指的是中世纪的西方……好吧，僵尸和龙立刻让它脱离了纯粹历史小说的范畴。对，所以也许我们可以——我是说，让我们把这两者都看一下——所以“电影过去的幽灵”（Ghost of film past）提出了一个问题：龙的idea到底起源于哪里？其中一个答案显然很明确，对吧？它来自中世纪文学，对吧？
but more than that it's it's it's in a way it's an. But more than that, in a way, it's showing the Middle Ages in which dragons are real is kind of true to a certain way in which medieval people did understand the world because they did think that dragons kind of existed. So before the sack of Lindisfarne by the Vikings, fiery dragons are seen in the sky. Are they not comets and they're just not comets? Well, that's what we would say. But in the Chronicle, it says it, fiery dragons are seen in the sky. Are they not comets?
但不仅于此，它在某种程度上是一个……但不仅于此，在某种程度上，展现一个龙真实存在的中世纪，在某种程度上契合了中世纪人们理解世界的方式，因为他们确实认为龙是存在的。因此，在维京人洗劫林迪斯法恩（Lindisfarne）之前，天空中就曾出现过火龙。它们难道不是彗星吗，真的不是彗星吗？嗯，我们会这么说。但在《编年史》中就是这么写的：“天空中出现了火龙。”它们难道不是彗星吗？
Are they just not comets? Well, that's what we would say. But in the Chronicle, it says it's fiery dragons. And you get reports from Armenia in the early 11th century of dragons sweeping down and vomiting fire. And you get this incredible report. I mean, one of my favorite passages in the whole of medieval literature, again, early 11th century of a monk from regensburg crossing the hungarian
它们真的不是彗星吗？嗯，我们会这么说。但在《编年史》中，它写的是“火龙”。11世纪初，你还能从亚美尼亚听到关于龙俯冲下来喷吐烈火的报道。你还会听到这样不可思议的报道——我的意思是，在整部中世纪文学中，我最喜欢的段落之一，同样是11世纪初，一个来自雷根斯堡（Regensburg）的修道士穿过匈牙利
plain and he's describing the details of his trip you know i saw this castle it's kind of interesting path oh and then a dragon shadowed me he had a huge head and he had scales like like metal plates and then he flew off where's this germany uh hungary hungary well who knew so so of course i mean we might say obviously he'd eaten something or drunk something or whatever. He had too much cheese. Yes, he had too much cheese. But in a way, one thing that is kind of, I think, great about Game of Thrones is that it does import the supernatural and the sensational in a way that is true to the way that medieval people perhaps did see the world. Well, I suppose if you're a Western medieval person, a hippopotamus, a rhinoceros, a Komodo dragon, they're just as fantastic.
平原，他描述了自己旅行的细节，你知道：“我看到了这座城堡，那条小路挺有意思的……哦，然后一条龙尾随了我。它有一个巨大的头，身上长着像金属板一样的鳞片，然后它飞走了。”这是哪里？德国？匈牙利。匈牙利？好吧，谁能想到呢！所以，当然了，我们可能会说，显然他当时吃坏了东西、喝多了或者别的什么。他奶酪吃太多了。是的，他奶酪吃太多了。但在某种程度上，《权力的游戏》最棒的一点，我认为，在于它引入超自然和轰动效应的方式，确实忠实于中世纪人们看待世界的方式。嗯，我想如果你是个中世纪的西方人，河马、犀牛、科莫多巨蜥，对你来说同样是奇幻生物。
Yeah. I mean, why shouldn't a dragon fly? I mean, it's not, well, dinosaurs, birds. But there is another way in which obviously dragons, the role that they play in this series is incredibly modern because they are a kind of super weapon. They are the equivalent of, of, of a bomb,
对。我的意思是，为什么龙不能飞呢？我的意思是，这并不是……好吧，恐龙，鸟类。但龙在剧中所扮演的角色，在另一个层面上显然是极其现代的，因为它们是一种超级武器。它们相当于……相当于一枚炸弹、
a block, a fleet of bombers. Or the ring in the Lord of the Rings is a super weapon, isn't it? And that the prospect of using the ring hangs over the Lord of the Rings. I mean, this is slightly different, but isn't it the same thing that dragons,
一个轰炸机编队。或者《指环王》里的魔戒就是一种超级武器，对吧？而使用魔戒的可能性一直悬在《指环王》的头上。我的意思是，这略有不同，但难道不是一回事吗？龙——
there's a fear in the show and in the books that the possession of dragons will corrupt you. It's a symbol of ultimate power and the power of life and death over thousands, if not millions of people. Well, that's a tiny bit like Tolkien's ring, but it's also the way that, it's very modern because it's the way that we now think
剧中和书中的人们有一种恐惧，即拥有龙会让你腐化。它是终极权力的象征，是对成千上万甚至数百万人生死予取予夺的权力。嗯，这有点像托尔金的魔戒，但这也是一种方式……它非常现代，因为这是我们现在看待大规模杀伤性武器的方式。你知道，比如二战中的核武器……但它也非常符合——你知道——90年代及21世纪初的现实情况，当时权力极大的人确实利用空中力量对敌方城市造成了毁灭性的打击。好吧，我的意思是，关于《权力的游戏》是在20世纪90年代创作的，我有一大堆理论。我的意思是，对我来说，也许我们……也许我们现在就该探讨这个，在讲到异鬼之前，既然我们在谈论90年代——
of weapons of mass destruction. You know, the nuclear weapons in World War II, for example but also it's it's very true to a very you know the circumstances of the 90s and and early years of 21st century when highly powerful people did use aerial power to afflict devastation on enemy cities well i mean i have a whole ton of theories about game of thrones being written in the 1990s i mean to me maybe we well maybe we should get into this now before we get to the zombies um since we're talking about the 90s so george orr martin starts writing this these books in sort of the early to mid 1990s and i've always thought i haven't maybe nobody maybe people think this is mad because i haven't really seen anyone argue this but i always think he starts writing
乔治·R·R·马丁大约在20世纪90年代初到中期开始创作这些书。我一直觉得——也许没人这么想，也许大家觉得这太疯狂了，因为我真的没见过其他人这么争论过——但我总是觉得，他开始创作这些书的时候，正值柏林墙倒塌、冷战结束、“历史的终结”被宣告，然后历史又某种程度上重新启动了。南斯拉夫等地发生了可怕的内战，或者卢旺达发生了种族灭绝。这种感觉日复一日地占据着头条新闻：高层人士、
these books at the point at which the Berlin Wall has come down, the Cold War is over, the end of history has been proclaimed, and then history kind of restarts. And you have these hideous civil wars in places like Yugoslavia or the genocide in Rwanda. And you have this sense played out in the headlines for day after day that sort of top people,
精英阶层做出的决定，在底层普通百姓的村庄里产生了最可怕的后果，这种感觉就像是邻居把矛头指向邻居。而且，你知道，正如乔治·R·R·马丁所称的那些“小民”（small folk），他们为大人物和显贵们的恩怨付出了代价。波斯尼亚就是这样一个例子。
the elite, are taking decisions that have the most horrific consequences on the ground in ordinary people's villages, it's kind of neighbor turns on neighbor. And sort of, you know, the sort of the small folk, as I think George R.R. Martin calls them, they pay the price for the feuds of the great and the good. So Bosnia is an example of that.
读到他的故事中发生的事情——这也是它与托尔金不同的地方——战争爆发了，也就是为争夺七大王国的战争。你看到的不再仅仅是通过贵族们的眼睛，而是开始看到这些村庄里普通人的遭遇。我当时就想……而小说中尤其如此，对吧？比电视剧里明显得多！
And reading what happens in his story, and this is where it differs from Tolkien, the war starts, so the war for the Seven Kingdoms. And instead of you seeing it purely through the eyes of the nobles, you start to see the consequences for these people in these villages. And I thought at the time... And that's particularly true of the novels, isn't it? Much more than in the TV show.
小说里更是如此，确切地说。角色们穿过这些烧毁的、支离破碎的村庄，感觉就像三十年战争和第二次世界大战中的场景。人们流离失所，把财产装在手推车上。有很多强奸。有大量的性暴力，这感觉非常具有90年代和21世纪初的特征。这是50年代的人绝不会写到的东西，而这恰恰发生在人们开始书写红军1945年入侵德国时犯下的强奸罪行之类的时期……所以这感觉非常契合当下，我认为这把《权力的游戏》非常明确地根植于20世纪末的语境中——它绝不可能在之前的任何时期被创作出来。我认为所有伟大的对历史的虚构性重新校准都是如此。托尔金也是如此，《指环王》深受两次世界大战的影响；
Much more in the novels, exactly. The characters travel through these sort of burned out, shattered villages that feel like something from the Thirty Years' War and the Second World War. People have fled. They put their possessions on carts. There's a lot of rape. There's tons of sexual violence, which feels very 1990s, early 21st century. Something that people wouldn't have written about 50 years earlier and it's at precisely the point when people are writing about the red army's rapes when they invaded germany in 1945 or something so it feels very of the moment and i think that roots game of thrones very clearly in the sort of late 20th 30th it couldn't have been written at any previous point and i think that's that's true of all great recalibrations fictional recalibrations of history so it's true of tolkien that he's hugely lord of the rings is hugely informed by
司各特深受他所处的时代气候的影响；而《权力的游戏》显然既关乎21世纪，也关乎它所设定的任何历史时期。所以，接下来谈谈僵尸，那些潜伏在长城之外的死者，我们有一个来自……是的，安格斯·科尔韦尔（Angus Colwell）的问题，他说：乔治·R·R·马丁曾表示，作为僵尸的异鬼，是气候变化的隐喻。
the two world wars scott is hugely informed by the the climate in which he's writing and obviously game of thrones is as much about the 21st century as it is about whatever period it's set in and so um moving on to the zombies, the dead who lurk beyond the wall, we've got a question from, yes, Angus Colwell, who says, George R.R. Martin said, the White Walkers, who are the zombies, were a climate change analogy.
是的，那种厄运感。所以，对，经常出现的副歌是“凛冬将至”。但从某种意义上说，这有点像是，你知道的，“酷暑将至”。焦灼的夏天将至。“夏天将至”听起来可没有同样的联想。不，确实没有。“太阳出来了”。从这个意义上说，它们是一个非常当代的寓言。
Yeah, the sense of doom. Well, so yeah, the recurring refrain is winter is coming. But in a sense, it's kind of, you know, heat is coming. Scorching summer is coming. Summer is coming doesn't quite have the same connotation. No, it doesn't. Here comes the sun. So in that sense, they're a very contemporary allegory.
但与此同时，死者从坟墓中爬出来的想法，确实困扰着早期中世纪的想象力，比如从死里复活的“德劳格”（Draugr）的北欧传说。从某种意义上说，《贝奥武夫》（Beowulf）里也有怪物。所以我觉得你可以追溯得更早。我没说错吧，《吉尔伽美什史诗》（Epic of Gilgamesh）里，伊什塔尔（Ishtar）就曾威胁要将死者从坟墓中唤醒，类似这样的情节？对，对。在《奥德赛》里也有。但我认为这具体植根于北欧、斯堪的纳维亚和盎格鲁-撒克逊的传统。所以，我认为《权力的游戏》有趣的地方在于，它使用了真实的材料，并赋予其非常当代的视角。
But at the same time, the idea of the dead rising from their grave is something that did haunt certainly the early medieval imagination, the kind of Norse legends of the Drago who rise from the dead. I mean, in a sense, Beowulf is kind of the monster. So I think you can go back even further. Am I not right in saying that the epic of Gilgamesh, Ishtar, threatens to raise the dead
这显然就是它如此成功的原因，我想。嗯，这是一个巨大的元素。这可能也是许多粉丝对我们的播客所期待的——我的意思是，人们几乎是一丝不苟地把整部剧过了一遍——一丝不苟地，我的意思是你可以这样解读《权力的游戏》……你一丝不苟地分析《权力的游戏》并说道：“好吧，他是爱德华一世，他是爱德华四世，这家伙是……瑟曦·兰尼斯特（Cersei Lannister）是安茹的玛格丽特（Margaret of Anjou）”，或者，你知道的，你可以这样做，对吧？人们确实这么做过，或者他们把所有的地点都过了一遍。所以这里的地理环境非常有趣，因为地理环境显然是虚构的。其中很多地方都是不列颠群岛，但设定在历史上的不同时期。
from their graves or some such? Yeah, yeah. And it's in the Odyssey as well. But I think this is specifically rooted in kind of Norse, Scandinavian, Anglo-Saxon traditions. Yeah. So I think that's what's interesting about Game of Thrones is that it uses authentic historical material and gives it a very contemporary spin.
你认可这种说法吗？所以它几乎就像是不同的时区。嗯，多米尼克，关于这一点，大卫·斯普拉克林（David Spracking）有一个提问：《权力的游戏》沿用了熟悉的套路，将北方描绘成粗犷但诚实，南方描绘成精致但颓废，东方描绘成野蛮且残酷，西方描绘成荒凉而奇特。这些与罗盘方位的关联，是不列颠及欧洲历史上的常态吗？我的意思是，是的，它有一种大陆视角的架构，因此其中带有中世纪欧洲的回音。但我确实认为，有趣的一点在于，不列颠历史在其中占据了绝对核心的地位。我认为这很有趣的原因是，马丁曾说过他的灵感来自于一套以13世纪到14世纪初为背景的法国小说《被诅咒的国王》（Les Rois Maudits）。但当他着手写作时，他明确锁定了不列颠历史。我想你甚至可以说这其实是英格兰历史，因为正如你所说，剧情的主要推动力显然是
And that's obviously why it's been as successful as it has, I think. Well, that's a huge element. And that's probably what a lot of fans will be expecting from our podcast actually that that i mean people have gone through the series kind of almost blow by blow um blow by blow i mean you can interpret that like this game of thrones um you go through game of thrones blow by blow and said okay this is he is edward I, he's Edward IV, this fellow is, you know, this Cersei Lannister is Margaret of Anjou, or, you know, you can do that, can't you? I mean, people have done it, or they've gone through all the places. So the geography is quite interesting, because the geography is clearly different. A lot of it is the British Isles, but set at different points
以玫瑰战争为基础的。嗯。兰开斯特和约克，史塔克和兰尼斯特，这简直是显而易见的，对吧？讲述玫瑰战争故事的宏大戏剧周期就是莎士比亚的历史剧。我不认为还有其他任何国家的传统能拥有这样一位伟大的作家，以如此深刻且具有影响力的方式来诠释历史。所以我们谈到了托尔金，我们谈到了司各特，但我认为归根结底，对这部作品影响巨大的是莎士比亚。原因在于，每一个说英语的人——
in history. Do you buy that? So it's sort of almost different time zones. Yeah, well, Dominic, on that point, there's a question from David Spracking. Game of Thrones follows familiar paths in representing the North as rough but honest, the South as sophisticated but decadent, East as barbaric and cruel, West as wild and strange. Are these associations with points of the compass
无论你在美国、不列颠还是其他任何地方——都会受到这种影响。所以当你想起中世纪时，你就会想起莎士比亚。嗯，我想这确实是真的。我的意思是，莎士比亚在……我的意思是，莎士比亚在美国显然极其受欢迎。因此，英国中世纪历史传到并被美国人理解时，往往是通过莎士比亚的镜头。我也觉得你绕不开托尔金。
constants in British European history? I mean, yeah, there is a kind of continental framing of it, so that there are echoes of medieval Europe. But I do think that one of the things that's interesting is the way that British history is absolutely central in this. And the reason that I think that's interesting is that Martin said that his inspiration was a series of French novels set in the 13th, early 14th century, Les Rois Maudits. But when he comes to write this, he fixes on specifically British history. And I guess you could say actually English history, because as you say, the prime motor of the plot is clearly
我的意思是，托尔金这个人基本上发明了高魔奇幻（high fantasy），或者至少将其大众化了。而且它必须设定在北方，其中总是交织着盎格鲁-撒克逊和北欧的传统，这部作品也是如此，对吧？所以在北方，在这个故事中，史塔克家族和临冬城（Winterfell）的世界，非常类似于盎格鲁-撒克逊的广厅（mead hall），对吧？我是说，奈德·史塔克（Ned Stark），作为你在第一本书中至少被邀请去投入感情的家族大家长，非常像是那种理想化的盎格鲁-撒克逊领主。你不觉得吗？他在宴请他的手下。我确实这么认为。而且我认为，这再次使得威斯特洛的世界难以被轻易定义。但这也引出了朱利安·伦诺克斯（Julian Lennox）提出的一个非常非常有趣的问题：《权力的游戏》所描绘的历史时期究竟是哪一段？
based on the Wars of the Roses. Yeah. Well, Lancaster and York, Starks and Lannister, I mean, it's blatantly obvious, isn't it? The great dramatic cycle that tells the story of the Wars of the Roses is Shakespeare's history plays. And I don't think that there is any other kind of national tradition that has a great writer who has interpreted history in quite so profound and influential a way. So we've talked about Tolkien, we've talked about Scott, but I think ultimately the huge influence on this is Shakespeare. And the reason for that is that everyone who speaks English,
嗯，这看起来是个简单的问题，但我认为它有点棘手。在河湾地（the Reach），他们似乎处于文艺复兴时期，但也可能比那更早。在北方，他们是诺曼-撒克逊人吗？我们能说是1300年还是1000年？所以我觉得威斯特洛大陆，首都君临（King's Landing）的中心，有点像是……是伦敦吗？它有点像伦敦、君士坦丁堡之类的。君士坦丁堡，对。
whether you're in America, Britain, wherever, that is the influence. So when you think of the Middle Ages, you think of Shakespeare. Yeah, I suppose that's true. I mean, well, I think Shakespeare is, I mean, Shakespeare is obviously enormously popular in America. And so English medieval history has arrived, is understood in America often through the lens of Shakespeare. I also think you can't get away from Tolkien.
对。所以它是各种地方的混合体。但住在那里的人基本上是15世纪末的都铎（Tudor）人。没错。然后你向北走，穿过的土地似乎基本上属于14世纪。对。它们有点像盛期中世纪，对吧？百年战争。对。剧情线来自百年战争。然后你再往北走。来到临冬城，史塔克家族的所在地，你在那里身处一个盎格鲁-撒克逊的世界；而在海岸边，你拥有显然属于维京人的岛屿——也就是铁民（Ironborn），他们是航海家，对吧？——显然以维京人为原型。你再往北走，就会来到
I mean, Tolkien is the person who basically invents high fantasy, or at least popularizes it. And the idea that it has to be in the North, that there are always kind of Anglo-Saxon and Norse traditions at play, which is true with this, right? So in the North, in this story, the world of the Starks and Winterfell, it's very kind of Anglo-Saxon mead hall, isn't it? I mean, Ned Stark, who is the sort of family patriarch
这堵巨大的冰墙，乔治·R·R·马丁曾说过它是以哈德良长城为原型的。所以那是一个罗马建筑。然后你真正回溯了时间，因为你在苏格兰。好吧，你在冰河时代，因为你身处一片被冰雪覆盖的土地。所以，是的。好吧，我觉得这挺有意思的。但对我也很有趣的是，汤姆，
that you're invited to invest in, in the first book at least, he's very much the sort of idealized Anglo-Saxon lord. Don't you think? He's sort of feasting his men. I do. And I think, again, that this is kind of what makes the world of Westeros hard to pin down. But also kind of very, very interesting question from Julian Lennox. What is the exact period of history depicted in Game of Thrones?
如果你看看东方。所以马丁确实捕捉到了一种你在托尔金作品中能看到的东西，某种你在大量关于世界的西方写作中——这种东方主义式的写作中——能看到的东西，即西方是直言不讳且诚实的，而东方则是精致、腐败、极其残酷，可能还高深莫测。所以，你知道，在东方，他们有那些巨大的奴隶制城市，非常富有，非常精致，但又有着不可理喻的虐待狂倾向、充满异国情调，诸如此类
Well, it seems like an easy answer, but I think it's a bit tricky. In the Reach, they seem to be in the Renaissance, but maybe it's earlier than that. In the North, are they Norman Saxons? Can we say 1300 or 1000? So I think that the continent of Westeros, the centre of King's Landing is kind of... It's London? It's kind of London, Constantinople, whatever. Constantinople, yeah.
种种。从某种意义上说，你知道的，西方……所以我们看待威斯特洛的方式尚未经历去殖民化，因为我们看到的每一面——你知道，事实并非如此——我们是通过非常西部的镜头来看待一切的。我完全……是的，我完全赞同，我认为这再次构成了它吸引许多人的部分原因——你不会遇到20世纪初那种戏剧或小说，里面有白人猎人或白人英雄前往偏远城市（比如《所罗门王的宝藏》），或者丁丁前往失落的
Yeah. So it's a mix of places. But the people who live there are basically late 15th century Tudor. Right. Yeah. Then you move northwards and you go through lands that seem to be basically 14th century. Yeah. They're kind of high medieval, aren't they? Hundred Years' War. Yeah. The plot lines coming from the Hundred Years' War. Then you go further north. So into Winterfell, the home of the Starks there you are in an anglo-saxon world and off the coast you have islands that are clearly viking so they're the ironborn who are seafarers yeah um clearly based on the vikings you go further north yet and you come to this
玛雅城市之类的地方，然后运用日食的知识或其他什么，把奴隶从他们野蛮的主人手中解放出来——而在《权力的游戏》中你可以这样做，因为你提到的那个角色，也就是龙之母丹妮莉丝·塔加利安（Daenerys Targaryen），她出身于一长串能够唤醒龙的国王和女王血脉，那是他们力量的源泉。她基本上被当作婚姻奴隶，卖给了一个野蛮的游牧首领——那种有点像斯基泰人（Scythians）兼匈奴兼蒙古人的角色。她成为了他们的女王，然后利用这支军队和她的龙去解放了奴隶的王国……是的，我们之前还在谈论阿兹特克人和科尔特的到来，对吧？传统的做法是，从征服之后一直贯穿
vast wall of ice that george rr martin has said was based on hadrian's wall so that's a roman construction and then you got really back in time because you're in Scotland. Well, you're in the Ice Age because you're in a land covered with ice. So yeah. Okay. I think that's kind of interesting. But also what's interesting to me, Tom,
整个19世纪到20世纪，对阿兹特克帝国征服的描绘往往将其视为将人们从从事血腥祭祀的野蛮统治者、祭司和国王手中解放出来的过程。从政治上讲，这现在已经不再被允许了，但这是一个非常具有戏剧性的故事。这是一种非常戏剧化的呈现方式。她不是把奴隶主钉死在十字架上了吗？她确实这么做了，是的。然后她最终用她的龙把整个威斯特洛都烧成了灰烬。所以这并不是对她纯粹歌颂性的呈现，但她确实是白人救世主的精髓——我的意思是，她的头发不能再金了，她就是那种——
is if you look east. So Martin does absolutely capture something that you get in Tolkien and something that actually you get in so much Western writing about the world, you know, orientalizing writing, which is that the West is kind of plain speaking and honest, and the East is sophisticated and corrupt and incredibly cruel, possibly inscrutable as well. So, you know, in the East, they have these great slaver cities, they're very rich, they're very sophisticated, but they're impossibly sadistic and exotic and all of that
就像是去乞力马扎罗山参加“喜剧救济”（Comic Relief）慈善行的那种人，对吧？是的。带着一条龙。
sort of stuff. And in a way you know you know west so the way we think about westeros has yet to be decolonized because we see everything we know it's not we see everything through a very western lens i complete yes i completely agree and i think that that that that again is part of the appeal of it for lots of people is that you can't have the kind of um dramas that that or novels that you got in the early 20th century where you have white hunters or white heroes going to remote cities king solomon's mines or yeah tintin going to lost um mayan cities or whatever and invoking um you know the knowledge of eclipses or or whatever, to liberate slaves from their barbaric owners,
但结果却错得离谱。不过她是一个很有趣的角色，因为她某种程度上是个……我的意思是，她是个流亡王位觊觎者。好吧，用“觊觎者”可能不太准确，因为她确实对王位有着非常正当的要求。但她有点像个詹姆斯党（Jacobite）式的人物，对吧？是的，她就是邦妮·普林斯·查理（Bonnie Prince Charlie）。是的，她就是海那边的主权女王。而你——最有趣的是，希望我们不会剧透。好吧，我们就是要剧透。
which in Game of Thrones you can, because the figure you mentioned, Daenerys Targaryen, who is the mother of dragons, who comes from a long line of kings and queens who are able to raise dragons, and that's the source of their power. And she is kind of basically sold into marital slavery to a barbarous leader of, of kind of Scythians stroke Hums quote stroke Mongols. And she becomes their queen and then uses this army and her dragons to, to, to liberate kingdoms of slaves yeah and we and we we were talking about the aztecs and the arrival of cortez yeah and the the way in which traditionally over the course of you know following the conquest right the way through
但我的意思是，如果你到现在还没看过这部电视剧，你大概也不会去看了，而小说结局可能会有所不同，谁知道呢，因为他显然还没写完。但你知道，这里有一个巨大的争议：在小说结尾、剧集结尾，所有那些曾经在她身上投资感情的人都大失所望，因为她黑化了。你知道的，她占领了首都君临，
the 19th into the 20th century the way that the the conquest of the Aztec empire tended to be portrayed was as a liberation of people from barbarous rulers and priests and kings who were engaging in bloody sacrifice. And that is politically no longer permissible, but it is a very dramatic story. It's a very dramatic way of presenting it. Doesn't she crucify the slavers? She does, yes. And then she ends up incinerating the whole of west ross with her dragons so it's it is it's it's not a a kind of purely laudatory presentation of her but she is the very essence of a white savior i mean her her hair could not be more blonde she is she's she's somebody going on a comic relief trip to kilimanjaro, isn't she? Yes. With a dragon.
并将她的龙转向城中的百姓，把所有人都化为灰烬。然后在最后一集里，她几乎成了一个极权主义风格的统治者，身后跟着龙，密密麻麻的奴隶士兵列阵向她顶礼膜拜，这场景就像是一场纽伦堡集会。每个人都感到极其震惊，所有那些爱她并以她的名字给孩子起名的剧迷们都纷纷表示：“天哪，事情怎么会变成这样，跟我预想的完全不一样！”但我爱极了这一段。
But it's gone horribly wrong. But she's an interesting character because she's a kind of, I mean, she's a pretender. Well, she's not, a pretender is probably not quite the right word because she does have a very good claim to the throne. But she's a kind of Jacobite figure, isn't she? Yeah, she's Bonnie Prince Charlie. Yeah, she's the queen over the water. And you're, what's so interesting now, I hope we're not going to ruin this for people. Well, we are going to ruin it.
我其实觉得这非常棒，而且非常符合生活逻辑，因为它是……我的意思是，也许你会这么认为，正如你所说，“哦，这就是博克主义（Burkianism）的精髓，她摧毁了所有的传统。”她是个罗伯斯庇尔式的人物，遥相呼应了我们的法国大革命播客。她充满了理想主义，但这却把她变成了一个可怕的怪物。
But I mean, if you haven't seen the TV series by now,'re probably not going to and the books may turn out differently who knows because he obviously hasn't finished but you know there's this huge controversy because at the end of the books at the end of the series all these people who had invested in her were really disappointed because she turned evil and you know she captures the capital king's landing Landing, and she turns her dragons on the people and they incinerate everybody. And then the very final episode, she's this almost sort of totalitarian style ruler, the dragons behind her,
我真的觉得这相当符合她的人设逻辑以及整部剧的逻辑。……播客，她充满了理想主义，但这却把她变成了一个可怕的怪物。我真的觉得这相当符合她的人设逻辑以及整部剧的逻辑。我觉得我们两个人在大结局的处理方式上属于极少数派。对，我其实也挺喜欢《反腐先锋》（Line of Duty）大结局的那种处理方式。哦，那太疯狂了……好吧，多米尼克，既然我们在谈论丹妮莉丝·塔加利安，保罗·邓肯（Paul Duncan）有个提问：历史上谁是与丹妮莉丝·塔加利安最相似的对比人物？有没有哪个王位觊觎者像她那样偏离正轨得如此离谱？
massed ranks of slave soldiers kind of doing homage to her in this sort of Nuremberg rally kind of scene. And everybody was very shocked, all the viewers who loved her and had named their children after her. Yes. Oh God, this just hasn't turned out as I expected. But I loved that.
你显然已经有答案了，不然你不会问这个问题。不，不，我们刚才在谈论丹妮莉丝·塔加利安。我正在临时开动脑筋呢。所以她被嫁给了一个野蛮的国王。对。哦。还有一个罗马女皇……好吧，
I actually thought that was very good and very true to life because it was, I mean, maybe you would think that from, you know, you say, oh, this is the essence of sort of Burkeanism, that she's destroyed all these traditions. And she's a sort of Robespierre figure, nodding back to our French Revolution podcast. She's suffused with idealism, but it's turned her into this dreadful monster.
一个皇帝的女儿。我懂你要往哪儿扯了。对，这位……
And I thought that was actually pretty true to the logic of her character and of the show. podcast she's suffused with idealism but it's turned her into this dreadful monster and i i thought that was actually pretty true to the logic of her character and of the show i think both of us are in a massive minority in the way that it ended i i yeah i i like the way that um line of duty ended as well oh that is madness um well dominic while we're on the subject of daenerys Targaryen, there's a question from Paul Duncan. Who from history is the best comparison to Daenerys Targaryen? Did any pretenders get as massively sidetracked as she does?
最后一位同时统治罗马帝国东西两半的罗马皇帝。她叫加拉·普拉西迪娅（Galla Placidia）。她基本上在公元410年罗马遭到洗劫后被西哥特人俘虏了。她最终……在公元410年罗马遭到洗劫后，嫁给了西哥特国王。所以我觉得这是一个挺有趣的平行历史，也许有点类似。对，我接受这个说法。朱迪思·赫伦（Judith Heron）在她的书《拉韦纳》（Ravenna）中写到过她，对吧？没错，是的。因为她后来——就像丹妮莉丝所做的那样——离开了她的丈夫，回到了罗马的权力中心，成为了某种伟大的母系大家长式的人物。但还有另一个人物。所以我们之前谈到龙基本上……你知道的，你可以看出这与西方的空中力量有相似之处。而丹妮莉丝则将自己视为一个极其不合时宜的自由主义解放者。
You've obviously got an answer because you wouldn't have asked it. No, no, we were talking about Daenerys Targaryen. I'm thinking on the hoop here. So she gets married off to a barbarian king. Yeah. Oh. And there was a Roman Empress. Well,
她就是威廉·威伯福斯（William Wilberforce），将自由带给远方土地上受压迫的民众，却在这个过程中造成了可怕的浩劫和破坏。所以我要说，除了加拉·普拉西迪娅，丹妮莉丝·塔加利安身上或许还有托尼·布莱尔（Tony Blair）的影子。托尼·布莱尔！哦，天哪。
a daughter of, of, of an emperor. I know where you're going with this. Yeah. The, who, who,
我可没料到这个。艾米莉·克拉克（Emilia Clarke），我看不出她跟托尼·布莱尔有什么神似之处。我觉得她演不出那种感觉。你真的觉得丹妮莉丝·塔加利安像托尼·布莱尔？你没看到托尼最近那一头长发吗？其实，确实如此。他确实有过那样的发型。他身上确实有一种塔加利安的范儿。
the last Roman Emperor to rule both the East and Western halves of the Roman Empire. She was called Gallop Placidia. And she, basically got captured by the Visigoths after the sack of Rome in 410. And she ends up, marrying the Visigoth after the sack of Rome in 410. And she ends up marrying the Visigothic king. So I think that's a kind of interesting parallel, maybe kind of floating around. Yeah, I buy that. Judith Heron writes about her in her book, Ravenna, doesn't she? That's right. Yes. Because she then, rather like Daenerys does, she leaves her husband and
对，他确实有。我的意思是，一种略带饱经沧桑的塔加利安风格。那你打算怎么论证这一点？她代表了第三条道路？不，因为布莱尔在世界各地派遣了许多军事任务——塞拉利昂、波斯尼亚、科索沃……对，科索沃，你知道的，到处去帮助受压迫的人民。对，科索沃好像有一尊他的雕像，对吧？然后他在伊拉克试图故技重施，结果搞得一团糟，一切都被毁灭了。所以，哇，这就是我的论据：
goes back to the Roman centers of power and becomes a kind of great matriarchal figure. But there is another figure. So we've talked about how dragons basically, you know, you, you can see that there are parallels there to Western air power. And Daenerys sees herself as rather anachronistically as a kind of great
丹妮莉丝·塔加利安的整个故事就是一个寓言。如果你的历史出版事业搞不下去了，我想你应该去写一本关于丹妮莉丝·塔加利安和托尼·布莱尔的平行传记，我觉得这主意不错。嗯，我告诉你我觉得《权力的游戏》最有趣的地方在哪里，汤姆，我很惊讶你竟然没提到这个：我觉得是它的那种 sensibility（基调/敏感度）。这种基调与《指环王》截然不同。我认为这就是——我的意思是，这也是许多人对此的看法。它不完全是一个反托尔金的作品，但它有点像——
liberal liberator. She's William Wilberforce. Bringing freedom to oppressed masses in far off lands. But wrecking terrible havoc and destruction by doing so. So I would say, as well as Galapagosidia, perhaps there's an element in Daenerys Targaryen of Tony Blair. Tony Blair. Oh my word.
不过它确实是，对吧？它某种程度上是公开的。我的意思是，难道……菲利普·普尔曼（Philip Pullman）才是反托尔金的，对吧？我的意思是，他是反刘易斯的。他是反《纳尼亚》的。是的，没错。你说得对。
I didn't see that coming. Emilia Clarke, I don't see her as a dead ringer for Tony Blair. I don't think she could carry that off. You honestly think Daenerys Targaryen is like Tony Blair? You saw Tony's long hair recently? Actually, that's true. He did have that. It's quite a Targaryen look to him.
我觉得马丁就是反托尔金的，因为他有一句名言：“阿拉贡的税收政策是什么？”他提出了许多棘手的问题，比如小兽人后来怎么样了？谁会在乎阿拉贡的税收政策啊？难道有人读《指环王》时，真的会去琢磨刚铎（Gondor）的个人所得税吗？嗯，我的意思是，这确实引出了一个有趣的点，也许我们应该在休息之后再探讨。但《权力的游戏》的粉丝们经常说的一点是，它比——比如说比《指环王》要准确得多，并且对中世纪的生活状况进行了准确的描绘。我简直不能更反对了。作为对中世纪的描绘，它极其不准确。而且我认为我已经公开表态过，我说我非常喜欢它。当我读原著时，我简直彻底着迷了。我觉得里面有很多东西确实为现实中的事件提供了迷人的镜鉴。
Yeah, he did. I mean, a kind of slightly ravaged Targaryen. So how are you going to justify this? She's the third way. No, because Blair sent out lots of military missions around the world sierra leone to bosnia kosovo yeah kosovo you know helping out oppressed peoples everywhere yeah there's a statue of him isn't there in kosovo i think and then he tries to pull the same trick in iraq and it all gets horribly wrong and everything gets devastated so wow that's my case
但我认为，如果你对中世纪历史有任何兴趣的话，这就成了一个小问题：《权力的游戏》现在对许多人如何看待和解读中世纪产生了巨大的影响。为什么？你最大的、你最重大的、你最大的抱怨是什么？你最大的……我们要不要等休息之后再谈这个？
that the whole story of Daenerys Targaryen is a parable about if you're if the history publishing doesn't work out I think you should write a parallel biography of Daenerys Targaryen and Tony Blair I think that's good um I'll tell you what I think is interesting about Game of Thrones though Tom I'm surprised you haven't brought this up I think it's the sort of the sensibility of it so the sensibility is so different from the Lord of the Rings. And I think that's the – I mean, that's basically what a lot of people have seen this as. It's not quite an anti-Tolkien, but it's kind of –
哦，是要谈那个“C”开头的词吗？对，也许吧。哦，女士们先生们，斟满你们的酒杯吧，那些正在玩“汤姆·霍兰喝酒游戏”的朋友们。我想他休息回来后就要谈论基督教了。我很期待。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
It is, though, isn't it? It was kind of overtly. I mean, didn't – Well, Philip Pullman is the anti-Tolkien, isn't he? I mean, he's the anti-Lewis. He's the anti-Narnia. Yes, he is. You're right.
确实是这样，对吧？它某种程度上是明摆着的。我的意思是，难道没——好吧，菲利普·普尔曼是反托尔金的，对吧？我的意思是，他是反刘易斯的。他是反《纳尼亚传奇》的。是的，他是。你是对的。
I think Martin is the anti-Tolkien because he famously says, what was Aragorn's tax policy? And he asked difficult questions about what happened to the baby orcs. Yeah. Who cares about Aragorn's tax policy? Does anyone read the Lord of the Rings and really ask themselves about income tax in Gondor? Well, I mean, it does open an interesting point that perhaps
我觉得马丁才是反托尔金的，因为他有一句名言：阿拉贡的税收政策是什么？他提出了关于小半兽人怎么了的高难度问题。是的。谁会在乎阿拉贡的税收政策？有没有人读了《指环王》之后，真的会去问自己贡多尔的所得税问题？嗯，我的意思是，这确实引出一个有趣的点，也许
we should come to after a break. But one of the things that fans of Game of Thrones often say is that um it's much more accurate than yeah that say than the Lord of the Rings and it gives an accurate portrayal of what life was like particularly in the middle ages I could not disagree more I it is it is massively inaccurate as a portrayal of the Middle Ages. And I think that I've gone on record, I said I absolutely love it. I'm kind of completely hooked when I was reading the books. I think there's loads about it that does hold up fascinating mirrors to actual events.
我们应该在休息之后再谈。但是《权力的游戏》的粉丝们经常说的一件事是，嗯，它比，比如说，《指环王》要准确得多，而且它准确地描绘了当时的生活，特别是在中世纪。我完全不同意，我认为作为对中世纪的描绘，它极其不准确。而且我想我已经公开表态过，我说我绝对爱死它了。当我读这些书的时候，我简直完全迷上了。我觉得里面有很多内容确实为真实事件提供了一面迷人的镜子。
But I think that if you have any interest in medieval history, It's a slight problem. The Game of Thrones now has this huge influence on how lots of people see and interpret the Middle Ages. Why? What's your biggest, what's your great, what's your big complaint? What's your biggest... Should we come to that after the break?
但我觉得，如果你对中世纪历史有任何兴趣，这就会是一个小问题。如今《权力的游戏》对许多人如何看待和诠释中世纪产生了巨大的影响。为什么？你最大的、你最棒的、你最大的抱怨是什么？你最大的……我们要不要在休息之后再谈这个？
Oh, is it going to be the C word? Yeah, maybe. Oh, ladies and gentlemen, charge your glasses, those people who are playing the Tom Holland drinking game. I think he will be talking about Christianity after the break. I look forward to it. See you in a second. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
哦，难道要说到那个“基”字（指基督教）了吗？是的，也许吧。哦，女士们先生们，请举起你们的酒杯，那些在玩汤姆·霍兰德饮酒游戏的人。我想他休息之后会谈论基督教。我很期待。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The rest is history um tom holland is about to embark on a discussion
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The rest is history um tom holland is about to embark on a discussion|||
of the sensibility of game of thrones i think he will be talking about christianity you have been warned tom off you go you have two hours well i i'm sure christianity will will come up but i think that um talking more specifically about uh the idea that game of thrones in any way gives an accurate portrayal of of medieval life a more accurate portrayal say than than lord of the rings does this is based on the idea that uh medieval life was unspeakably brutal and that everyone just went around pillaging and raping all the time. So nasty, brutish and short. Hobbesian. No one would deny that it was a violent world,
of the sensibility of game of thrones i think he will be talking about christianity you have been warned tom off you go you have two hours well i i'm sure christianity will will come up but i think that um talking more specifically about uh the idea that game of thrones in any way gives an accurate portrayal of of medieval life a more accurate portrayal say than than lord of the rings does this is based on the idea that uh medieval life was unspeakably brutal and that everyone just went around pillaging and raping all the time. So nasty, brutish and short. Hobbesian. No one would deny that it was a violent world,|||
but it was not remotely on the scale of violence, as Game of Thrones suggests. And I think that on all kinds of levels, Game of Thrones is essentially giving an 18th century an enlightenment idea of what the Middle Ages was about. Okay. age between a supposed civilized age you know classical antiquity when all was light and people just sat talking about philosophy and then 18th century when the philosophes arrive and again everything is returned to light and everything in between is is is brutish and and violent and aggressive ages and people just go around slaughtering each other non-stop and um it's it's all raped i this is not true. Medieval civilization.
but it was not remotely on the scale of violence, as Game of Thrones suggests. And I think that on all kinds of levels, Game of Thrones is essentially giving an 18th century an enlightenment idea of what the Middle Ages was about. Okay. age between a supposed civilized age you know classical antiquity when all was light and people just sat talking about philosophy and then 18th century when the philosophes arrive and again everything is returned to light and everything in between is is is brutish and and violent and aggressive ages and people just go around slaughtering each other non-stop and um it's it's all raped i this is not true. Medieval civilization.|||
I mean, in many ways, medieval. So just on the level of warfare, actually, medieval warfare was far more codified. There were far more inhibitions about violence. And there were far more controls on the ability of state actors to wage war than there were either in the classical period or in the early modern period. Because armies are smaller, right mean absolutely yeah yes yes so the scale of violence that you see in game of thrones that's the kind of so the storming of cities the the destruction of entire populations that's the kind of thing the romans went in for it's not what by and large people in the middle ages did and when you get um the notorious example is um 1099 when the first crusaders
I mean, in many ways, medieval. So just on the level of warfare, actually, medieval warfare was far more codified. There were far more inhibitions about violence. And there were far more controls on the ability of state actors to wage war than there were either in the classical period or in the early modern period. Because armies are smaller, right mean absolutely yeah yes yes so the scale of violence that you see in game of thrones that's the kind of so the storming of cities the the destruction of entire populations that's the kind of thing the romans went in for it's not what by and large people in the middle ages did and when you get um the notorious example is um 1099 when the first crusaders|||
seized jerusalem and the streets supposedly run in blood the reason that that's remembered and and is kind of preserved is that it was exceptional it was the exception that proved the rule that scale of violence did not happen and the the vast kind of teeming armies that you get with um increasingly over the course of the show again this is you know you need vast kind of teeming armies that you get with um increasingly over the course of the show again this is you know you need a kind of early modern state to provide that level of violence but isn't one of the things that people think is as modern isn't it so interesting that people equate being being accurate and being a sort of a properly modern portrait of the past with being very cynical very bleak and drenched in sex and violence so in other
seized jerusalem and the streets supposedly run in blood the reason that that's remembered and and is kind of preserved is that it was exceptional it was the exception that proved the rule that scale of violence did not happen and the the vast kind of teeming armies that you get with um increasingly over the course of the show again this is you know you need vast kind of teeming armies that you get with um increasingly over the course of the show again this is you know you need a kind of early modern state to provide that level of violence but isn't one of the things that people think is as modern isn't it so interesting that people equate being being accurate and being a sort of a properly modern portrait of the past with being very cynical very bleak and drenched in sex and violence so in other|||
words people say oh tolkien's terribly unrealistic because people are nice to each other and some people are virtuous and people applaud george rr martin's portrait of human nature which is unbelievably sort of downbeat everybody is really horrible yeah anyone who is virtuous ends up dying basically uh everybody stabs each other in the back and it's an interesting reflection on our Everybody is really horrible. Anyone who is virtuous ends up dying, basically. Everybody stabs each other in the back. And it's an interesting reflection on our loss of trust and authority and our disenchantment with politics that we think that is a all kinds of attempts to regulate the violence inherent within mailed men with horses who by their nature can dominate and brutalize. So again, the 11th century, the period that we talked about in the episode on 1066, the period that sees the emergence of castles, sees the emergence of knights. This is also the age that sees um what's called the truce of god
words people say oh tolkien's terribly unrealistic because people are nice to each other and some people are virtuous and people applaud george rr martin's portrait of human nature which is unbelievably sort of downbeat everybody is really horrible yeah anyone who is virtuous ends up dying basically uh everybody stabs each other in the back and it's an interesting reflection on our Everybody is really horrible. Anyone who is virtuous ends up dying, basically. Everybody stabs each other in the back. And it's an interesting reflection on our loss of trust and authority and our disenchantment with politics that we think that is a all kinds of attempts to regulate the violence inherent within mailed men with horses who by their nature can dominate and brutalize. So again, the 11th century, the period that we talked about in the episode on 1066, the period that sees the emergence of castles, sees the emergence of knights. This is also the age that sees um what's called the truce of god|||
where churchmen bring out relics from churches and monasteries and succeed in compelling armed warriors to essentially kind of swear oaths that they will they will not brutalize those around them i mean of course these oaths were broken but it was assumed that that they would be obeyed and followed and there was you know i've just been reading over the lockdown i was reading chaucer and chaucer of course is always associated with with um bawdy and people having sex and people sticking ares out of windows and things like that. But on the,
where churchmen bring out relics from churches and monasteries and succeed in compelling armed warriors to essentially kind of swear oaths that they will they will not brutalize those around them i mean of course these oaths were broken but it was assumed that that they would be obeyed and followed and there was you know i've just been reading over the lockdown i was reading chaucer and chaucer of course is always associated with with um bawdy and people having sex and people sticking ares out of windows and things like that. But on the,|||
on the nightly level that the, the, the tales that deal with the things that nights do, the whole point is, is that they're not going around raping. So in the night's tale, the whole thing is, is that,
on the nightly level that the, the, the tales that deal with the things that nights do, the whole point is, is that they're not going around raping. So in the night's tale, the whole thing is, is that,|||
that you have two, two brother nights who spend years both hankering after the same lady. They do not rush out and seize her. And even when you do get a rape, so in The Wife of Bath's Tale, that rape is punished. The whole dynamic of the plot revolves around his attempt to avoid being executed for committing rape. So essentially, what Game of Thrones does not get is the way in which
that you have two, two brother nights who spend years both hankering after the same lady. They do not rush out and seize her. And even when you do get a rape, so in The Wife of Bath's Tale, that rape is punished. The whole dynamic of the plot revolves around his attempt to avoid being executed for committing rape. So essentially, what Game of Thrones does not get is the way in which|||
there are controlling ideologies, frameworks of morality, ethics that govern how warriors behave, certainly ethics that govern sexual behaviour, that are simply not reflected in the way that Game of Thrones shows it. Well, we've had tons of questions about this, actually, because people know your predilections. So Jim longhurst asked a question about who captured the human spirit best and you know is westeros sort of the the grimness without the buddhas christs and saints that made the real world livable carolina asked the question what did game of thrones misunderstand about christianity's impact on the medieval period so okay so some people say of Game of Thrones,
there are controlling ideologies, frameworks of morality, ethics that govern how warriors behave, certainly ethics that govern sexual behaviour, that are simply not reflected in the way that Game of Thrones shows it. Well, we've had tons of questions about this, actually, because people know your predilections. So Jim longhurst asked a question about who captured the human spirit best and you know is westeros sort of the the grimness without the buddhas christs and saints that made the real world livable carolina asked the question what did game of thrones misunderstand about christianity's impact on the medieval period so okay so some people say of Game of Thrones,|||
I mean, we're sort of creating straw men here, but I mean, they do exist. They say Game of Thrones is more realistic than Tolkien because it paints a medieval world in which there is a religion. There's seven gods, I think, the faith of the seven. And there's also this really interesting kind of reformation movement
I mean, we're sort of creating straw men here, but I mean, they do exist. They say Game of Thrones is more realistic than Tolkien because it paints a medieval world in which there is a religion. There's seven gods, I think, the faith of the seven. And there's also this really interesting kind of reformation movement|||
or this sort of evangelical movement um by a guy who's called the high sparrow and who's played by jonathan price and he's very pious and austere and he's this sort of this sort of purging flame with his acolytes and they savonarola yes yes well we've got a question about that somebody said is he you know david morgan they look like savonarola and his army of boys and young men now do you so savonarola the um what's he florentine yes who the bonfire of vanities and he summons all the the florentines to to chuck their fripperies into a great bonfire he basically runs florence doesn't he seven in the same way that the high sparrow in the is clearly based on him runs king's landing for a time and becomes the great the great sort of power now the question, I suppose, Tom, is do you think this does elevate
or this sort of evangelical movement um by a guy who's called the high sparrow and who's played by jonathan price and he's very pious and austere and he's this sort of this sort of purging flame with his acolytes and they savonarola yes yes well we've got a question about that somebody said is he you know david morgan they look like savonarola and his army of boys and young men now do you so savonarola the um what's he florentine yes who the bonfire of vanities and he summons all the the florentines to to chuck their fripperies into a great bonfire he basically runs florence doesn't he seven in the same way that the high sparrow in the is clearly based on him runs king's landing for a time and becomes the great the great sort of power now the question, I suppose, Tom, is do you think this does elevate|||
Game of Thrones above its predecessors in making it more realistic? Well, again, I repeat, I think it's an 18th century view that religion exists solely as a kind of fraudulent trick played on people. Yes, because none of them actually, this is interesting, none of them in Game of Thrones, I think, really believe in their religion. So they talk about the Faith of the Seven and they pay lip service to it, but nobody ever has these sort of inner crises where they say, sugar, I really am going to go to hell.
Game of Thrones above its predecessors in making it more realistic? Well, again, I repeat, I think it's an 18th century view that religion exists solely as a kind of fraudulent trick played on people. Yes, because none of them actually, this is interesting, none of them in Game of Thrones, I think, really believe in their religion. So they talk about the Faith of the Seven and they pay lip service to it, but nobody ever has these sort of inner crises where they say, sugar, I really am going to go to hell.|||
This is what I actually genuinely, you know, nobody seems to believe it other than fanatics. And even the fanatics are, you know, the kind of implication is that it's all about power and control. I mean, it's a very it's a very modern perspective on it a very modern take on it and that is why i think tolkien is is truer to the middle ages because tolkien of course was a very great scholar of medieval literature and yeah he entirely understood that and he was also a catholic himself so it he he believed it and the
This is what I actually genuinely, you know, nobody seems to believe it other than fanatics. And even the fanatics are, you know, the kind of implication is that it's all about power and control. I mean, it's a very it's a very modern perspective on it a very modern take on it and that is why i think tolkien is is truer to the middle ages because tolkien of course was a very great scholar of medieval literature and yeah he entirely understood that and he was also a catholic himself so it he he believed it and the|||
paradox is exactly as you fixed on that in lord of the rings there are no gods there are no priests there is no religion there are no temples no equivalent of churches um and yet it's saturated in a kind of theological understanding of the world that absolutely derives from um medieval literature um yeah the way that medieval people would have understood the world as being divided between good and evil um game of thrones isn't and so the the seeming realism i think is not realistic at all and particularly on the topic of sex um i mean the sex again a bit like the violence is more classical so the orgies people eating grapes yeah there's a real there's a real trend in um dramas about the classical world now to to show the kind of casual way in which you know in a
paradox is exactly as you fixed on that in lord of the rings there are no gods there are no priests there is no religion there are no temples no equivalent of churches um and yet it's saturated in a kind of theological understanding of the world that absolutely derives from um medieval literature um yeah the way that medieval people would have understood the world as being divided between good and evil um game of thrones isn't and so the the seeming realism i think is not realistic at all and particularly on the topic of sex um i mean the sex again a bit like the violence is more classical so the orgies people eating grapes yeah there's a real there's a real trend in um dramas about the classical world now to to show the kind of casual way in which you know in a|||
roman household um slaves for instance would have been treated um that that essentially their various orifices are the equivalent of urinal that they are they are there to be receptacles for the bodily fluids of the of the master and that is something that that you do you see it in in hbo series rome it's there in the new series that's out about um augustus's wife livia domina which is is good i recommend it um and it's absolutely in game of thrones as well but this is this is a kind of far more classical take um yeah we've got a question from um demetrius bogdansalis uh so hyped for the game of thrones episode hope it's not disappointing um i would like to hear your opinion on any roman inspiration that martin used in his work but the court is very roman isn't it
roman household um slaves for instance would have been treated um that that essentially their various orifices are the equivalent of urinal that they are they are there to be receptacles for the bodily fluids of the of the master and that is something that that you do you see it in in hbo series rome it's there in the new series that's out about um augustus's wife livia domina which is is good i recommend it um and it's absolutely in game of thrones as well but this is this is a kind of far more classical take um yeah we've got a question from um demetrius bogdansalis uh so hyped for the game of thrones episode hope it's not disappointing um i would like to hear your opinion on any roman inspiration that martin used in his work but the court is very roman isn't it|||
the king's landing politics yeah it is but i think um it's also deeply rooted in i claudius as so many of the kind of the great dramas of uh of 21st century american tv are it's hugely hugely influential and there are elements of the julia claudian court absolutely to the degree that um the guy who plays joffrey who who is essentially Jack Gleeson. For those who haven't seen it, he's the most terrifying ruler, perhaps, of the lot. Kind of young, murderous, sadistic teenager. Typical teenager. Channeling John Hurt in I, Claudius.
the king's landing politics yeah it is but i think um it's also deeply rooted in i claudius as so many of the kind of the great dramas of uh of 21st century american tv are it's hugely hugely influential and there are elements of the julia claudian court absolutely to the degree that um the guy who plays joffrey who who is essentially Jack Gleeson. For those who haven't seen it, he's the most terrifying ruler, perhaps, of the lot. Kind of young, murderous, sadistic teenager. Typical teenager. Channeling John Hurt in I, Claudius.|||
He's John Lennon. Go on. He's not John Lennon. He's John Hurt in I, Claudius. John Lennon gone it's not john lennon he's he's john hurt john lennon with the supreme power anyway he looks eerily like a portrait bust of caligula and i've always wondered whether that was deliberate but also that sort of idea of the of power corrupting you know of of supreme power being incarnated in one ruler and them using it for sexual excess for sadism that's very kind of sutonius isn't it rather than medieval again i think it's kind of there in enlightenment
He's John Lennon. Go on. He's not John Lennon. He's John Hurt in I, Claudius. John Lennon gone it's not john lennon he's he's john hurt john lennon with the supreme power anyway he looks eerily like a portrait bust of caligula and i've always wondered whether that was deliberate but also that sort of idea of the of power corrupting you know of of supreme power being incarnated in one ruler and them using it for sexual excess for sadism that's very kind of sutonius isn't it rather than medieval again i think it's kind of there in enlightenment|||
pornography actually i you know it's the marquis de sade really yeah i think that game of thrones is clearly there's all the kind of medieval stuff. And we just discussed maybe Roman stuff as well. There's the modern stuff. And then there's this kind of controlling 18th century sensibility that is mediating both of them. Which sort of sees the medieval world as this sort of cesspit of violence. So it is a kind of pornographer's fantasy in that sense, do you think? Yeah, to a degree.
pornography actually i you know it's the marquis de sade really yeah i think that game of thrones is clearly there's all the kind of medieval stuff. And we just discussed maybe Roman stuff as well. There's the modern stuff. And then there's this kind of controlling 18th century sensibility that is mediating both of them. Which sort of sees the medieval world as this sort of cesspit of violence. So it is a kind of pornographer's fantasy in that sense, do you think? Yeah, to a degree.|||
Because that's how pornographers in the 18th century certainly saw it. Yeah. Yeah. What about this? We've got a few questions about an event that people always mention, which I think a lot of people see as the sort of emblematic moment of the entire series, which is this event called the Red Wedding. Oh, my wife Sadie asked about that. Did she?
Because that's how pornographers in the 18th century certainly saw it. Yeah. Yeah. What about this? We've got a few questions about an event that people always mention, which I think a lot of people see as the sort of emblematic moment of the entire series, which is this event called the Red Wedding. Oh, my wife Sadie asked about that. Did she?|||
What was your opinion on that? What was the source for that so for those people those remaining listeners who are not game of thrones fans um the red wedding is this moment where this sort of heroic um young king is sort of henry v or something isn't he rob stark um who is the sort of king in the north he pitches up at this wedding and you've been invited to believe you've been led to believe that he's going to be one of the great victors of the whole series because he's such a heroic such a virtuous and noble sort of figure and basically the wedding all ends really horribly and the starks all massacred at the wedding and um it's shocking because it's a sort of breach of
What was your opinion on that? What was the source for that so for those people those remaining listeners who are not game of thrones fans um the red wedding is this moment where this sort of heroic um young king is sort of henry v or something isn't he rob stark um who is the sort of king in the north he pitches up at this wedding and you've been invited to believe you've been led to believe that he's going to be one of the great victors of the whole series because he's such a heroic such a virtuous and noble sort of figure and basically the wedding all ends really horribly and the starks all massacred at the wedding and um it's shocking because it's a sort of breach of|||
the laws of hospitality and all that and there is a precedent so of course it's it's it's scottish hospitality isn't it tom the um the precedent is an event called the black dinner the black dinner i think it's from the early 15th century the earl of douglas pitches up at the king's court king james's court and he is served a black bull's head a severed black bull's head which is a kind kind of symbol, you're going to die. And then he and I think his son or something like that are taken out and horribly murdered, and it's kind of remembered as this. But I suppose the reason it's remembered is because it's so unusual, because this kind of carry-on doesn't, apart from the massacre of Glencoe,
the laws of hospitality and all that and there is a precedent so of course it's it's it's scottish hospitality isn't it tom the um the precedent is an event called the black dinner the black dinner i think it's from the early 15th century the earl of douglas pitches up at the king's court king james's court and he is served a black bull's head a severed black bull's head which is a kind kind of symbol, you're going to die. And then he and I think his son or something like that are taken out and horribly murdered, and it's kind of remembered as this. But I suppose the reason it's remembered is because it's so unusual, because this kind of carry-on doesn't, apart from the massacre of Glencoe,|||
so the Scots do have form, but this sort of thing doesn't happen very often. It doesn't, and also it's not a wedding. So a wedding in the Middle Ages is a sacrament and to desecrate a sacramental event like a wedding is incredibly serious. People did kill each other in church. I mean, Thomas Beckett died in a church, didn't he? He was butchered by his own altar.
so the Scots do have form, but this sort of thing doesn't happen very often. It doesn't, and also it's not a wedding. So a wedding in the Middle Ages is a sacrament and to desecrate a sacramental event like a wedding is incredibly serious. People did kill each other in church. I mean, Thomas Beckett died in a church, didn't he? He was butchered by his own altar.|||
But again, the exception that proves the rule, the king is whipped through the streets of canterbury thomas is enshrined as a saint it's remembered as the most shocking thing imaginable um again this kind of violence is it doesn't really happen that's that's the point of it but what i would but dominic what i would say also just on the on on why game of thrones is so addictive and why's such fun, is that I think it does give you everything that a great historical drama does. It gives you the sense of being in a past period governed by strange customs, governed by strange ways of doing things, family dynamics, all the kind of stuff that you get from a drama about the Wars of the Roses or the Julia Claudian Court. But because it's fantasy, you have no idea what's going to happen yes that's why this has the i mean i remember reading it and go being devastated and there's a famous footage
But again, the exception that proves the rule, the king is whipped through the streets of canterbury thomas is enshrined as a saint it's remembered as the most shocking thing imaginable um again this kind of violence is it doesn't really happen that's that's the point of it but what i would but dominic what i would say also just on the on on why game of thrones is so addictive and why's such fun, is that I think it does give you everything that a great historical drama does. It gives you the sense of being in a past period governed by strange customs, governed by strange ways of doing things, family dynamics, all the kind of stuff that you get from a drama about the Wars of the Roses or the Julia Claudian Court. But because it's fantasy, you have no idea what's going to happen yes that's why this has the i mean i remember reading it and go being devastated and there's a famous footage|||
of people watching it on the on the tv adaptation and kind of gets pulling pillows over their heads and screaming who films themselves watching a tv program on the off charts that they're going to be go viral yeah but you'd never get that watching um you know shakespeare play about rich the third you know the princes in the tower are going to get it because that's yes happened yeah but doesn't actually doesn't the guy who perpetrates it doesn't he suffer a very shakespearean fate isn't he served his own children in a pie or something like that is it which is i remember yeah i think he is and that which is very shakespearean fate isn't he served his own children in a pie or something like that is it which is i remember yeah i think he is and that which is very shakespearean um let's do loads of questions because we should give the listeners the impression that we take them seriously and love them which we do we do but we should do it by answering their questions rather than ignoring
of people watching it on the on the tv adaptation and kind of gets pulling pillows over their heads and screaming who films themselves watching a tv program on the off charts that they're going to be go viral yeah but you'd never get that watching um you know shakespeare play about rich the third you know the princes in the tower are going to get it because that's yes happened yeah but doesn't actually doesn't the guy who perpetrates it doesn't he suffer a very shakespearean fate isn't he served his own children in a pie or something like that is it which is i remember yeah i think he is and that which is very shakespearean fate isn't he served his own children in a pie or something like that is it which is i remember yeah i think he is and that which is very shakespearean um let's do loads of questions because we should give the listeners the impression that we take them seriously and love them which we do we do but we should do it by answering their questions rather than ignoring|||
this colossal ream of paper that we've got in front of us so um we've got another question here from paul duncan go on He was really hogging the stage here. Well, he's going to be happy, even if no one else is. Is there any historical comparison to the doom of Valyria? So Valyria is this old ancient civilisation that has been destroyed and kind of swallowed up by the waters or something like that, or the flames or something like that. So it's clearly Atlantis, isn't it?
this colossal ream of paper that we've got in front of us so um we've got another question here from paul duncan go on He was really hogging the stage here. Well, he's going to be happy, even if no one else is. Is there any historical comparison to the doom of Valyria? So Valyria is this old ancient civilisation that has been destroyed and kind of swallowed up by the waters or something like that, or the flames or something like that. So it's clearly Atlantis, isn't it?|||
Or have you got some other um something else i suppose it's a you know civilizations do suffer apocalyptic fates we did the aztecs um just a couple of weeks ago didn't we chiotto acan so that's the city that predates the aztecs right that's the civilization that came before and they didn't know valeria is kind of rome right game of thrones it's kind of an ancient empire that was great and then has fallen and its ruins are because High Valyrian is a kind of Latin
Or have you got some other um something else i suppose it's a you know civilizations do suffer apocalyptic fates we did the aztecs um just a couple of weeks ago didn't we chiotto acan so that's the city that predates the aztecs right that's the civilization that came before and they didn't know valeria is kind of rome right game of thrones it's kind of an ancient empire that was great and then has fallen and its ruins are because High Valyrian is a kind of Latin|||
that they speak isn't it a grand prestigious language or something like that and I think maybe there's an element also of the famous Anglo-Saxon poem
that they speak isn't it a grand prestigious language or something like that and I think maybe there's an element also of the famous Anglo-Saxon poem|||
about looking at the ruins of Bath right imagining it as the work of giants and having no idea who could have built these astonishing structures Gibbon looking over the ruins of bath right imagining it as the work of giants and having no idea who could have built this these astonishing structures um so given looking over the ruins of rome yeah although he knew he wrote a book about it he knew better than anybody well maybe he didn't know and he had to
about looking at the ruins of Bath right imagining it as the work of giants and having no idea who could have built these astonishing structures Gibbon looking over the ruins of bath right imagining it as the work of giants and having no idea who could have built this these astonishing structures um so given looking over the ruins of rome yeah although he knew he wrote a book about it he knew better than anybody well maybe he didn't know and he had to|||
write the book and find out um uh okay william jensen he's written a question about toilets which i think will appeal to you um because you know a lot about people being killed on toilets he says is there something he's talking about people being killed on toilets. He says there's something... He's talking about the historical versus the mythical style. He says it's impossible to imagine Tolkien's characters, Saruman or Denethor, being killed on a toilet like Tywin Lannister. Martin is writing in a lower register,
write the book and find out um uh okay william jensen he's written a question about toilets which i think will appeal to you um because you know a lot about people being killed on toilets he says is there something he's talking about people being killed on toilets. He says there's something... He's talking about the historical versus the mythical style. He says it's impossible to imagine Tolkien's characters, Saruman or Denethor, being killed on a toilet like Tywin Lannister. Martin is writing in a lower register,|||
which we take as being more realistic. Well, that's an interesting question, isn't it, about registers and... Because people were killed on toilets in the medieval medieval don't you have some good stories about that harold bluetooth who gave his name to the um the technology yeah yeah to bluetooth um he uh he was having a he was fighting his son spain forkbeard i think we've already mentioned this on the podcast haven't we yeah it was 1066 yeah he got off his ship um had a crap as he was having a crap blake shot him in the ass so actually martin is being true to
which we take as being more realistic. Well, that's an interesting question, isn't it, about registers and... Because people were killed on toilets in the medieval medieval don't you have some good stories about that harold bluetooth who gave his name to the um the technology yeah yeah to bluetooth um he uh he was having a he was fighting his son spain forkbeard i think we've already mentioned this on the podcast haven't we yeah it was 1066 yeah he got off his ship um had a crap as he was having a crap blake shot him in the ass so actually martin is being true to|||
medieval form there but he's right though that it wouldn't happen in tolkien tolkien is right to you talking there are two registers aren't there there's the hobbits i mean i agree that they don't get shot in the arse but they kind of you know they have drink and yeah smoke pipes yeah um and that's um and then you have the high stuff, and that's going back to Shakespeare. So Henry IV, part one and two, you've got the high black verse of kings and nobles and so on, and then you've got all the prose of people in the taverns. Whereas Martin is writing almost entirely in one register,
medieval form there but he's right though that it wouldn't happen in tolkien tolkien is right to you talking there are two registers aren't there there's the hobbits i mean i agree that they don't get shot in the arse but they kind of you know they have drink and yeah smoke pipes yeah um and that's um and then you have the high stuff, and that's going back to Shakespeare. So Henry IV, part one and two, you've got the high black verse of kings and nobles and so on, and then you've got all the prose of people in the taverns. Whereas Martin is writing almost entirely in one register,|||
I would say. He's writing prose right through. So there's no sense of the kind of grandeur. And there's no sense even that the characters really aspire to that, I don't think, by and large. Except for Daenerys Targaryen Blair. I love that comparison. That's the one thing I shall
I would say. He's writing prose right through. So there's no sense of the kind of grandeur. And there's no sense even that the characters really aspire to that, I don't think, by and large. Except for Daenerys Targaryen Blair. I love that comparison. That's the one thing I shall|||
take from this podcast, from this entire series actually. Saramandingo says, was there a historical Iron Bank? I like the Iron Bank. So that's this sort of Renaissance-type institution which exists in Essos essos i can't remember which city which is the eastern continent and they're bankrolling a lot of the war aren't they so they're basically italian banks aren't they they're a sort of italian bank yeah venetian or florentine or genoese um there isn't really though because isn't the thing about the iron bank that it um it kind of if you default on your debts they will come and
take from this podcast, from this entire series actually. Saramandingo says, was there a historical Iron Bank? I like the Iron Bank. So that's this sort of Renaissance-type institution which exists in Essos essos i can't remember which city which is the eastern continent and they're bankrolling a lot of the war aren't they so they're basically italian banks aren't they they're a sort of italian bank yeah venetian or florentine or genoese um there isn't really though because isn't the thing about the iron bank that it um it kind of if you default on your debts they will come and|||
get you yes so they're a kind of mafia bank yes i suppose so i suppose medieval kings had you know they would default and then the banks would go bust yeah i suppose that's yes i suppose the florentines didn't have sufficient you know if you did borrow money they they probably couldn't do i don't know could they do much about it could they send mercenaries to go and get you or something i suppose you could sponsor a rival king couldn't you yeah well they probably would wouldn't they i mean sort of henry tudor yeah did that happen with henry the seventh i think it did well i mean so there was an element clearly must have been bankrolled i can't remember i think in wars of the roses there was kind of elements of
get you yes so they're a kind of mafia bank yes i suppose so i suppose medieval kings had you know they would default and then the banks would go bust yeah i suppose that's yes i suppose the florentines didn't have sufficient you know if you did borrow money they they probably couldn't do i don't know could they do much about it could they send mercenaries to go and get you or something i suppose you could sponsor a rival king couldn't you yeah well they probably would wouldn't they i mean sort of henry tudor yeah did that happen with henry the seventh i think it did well i mean so there was an element clearly must have been bankrolled i can't remember i think in wars of the roses there was kind of elements of|||
yeah financiers taking punts on rival kings we clearly need to know more about history before yeah before doing these podcasts uh what else um michael adam asked a question about the impact of game of thrones on jubrovnik that's something i know a lot about because i've been jubrovnik i've never been uh city walls are fantastic jubrovnik is a is a beautiful michael foot the former labor lead he's to go on holiday to jubrovnik is a beautiful... Michael Foote, the former Labour leader, used to go on holiday to Dubrovnik every year, which seems a bit repetitive to me. But it's a very nice city,
yeah financiers taking punts on rival kings we clearly need to know more about history before yeah before doing these podcasts uh what else um michael adam asked a question about the impact of game of thrones on jubrovnik that's something i know a lot about because i've been jubrovnik i've never been uh city walls are fantastic jubrovnik is a is a beautiful michael foot the former labor lead he's to go on holiday to jubrovnik is a beautiful... Michael Foote, the former Labour leader, used to go on holiday to Dubrovnik every year, which seems a bit repetitive to me. But it's a very nice city,|||
which has been utterly ruined by mass tourism. And actually, Game of Thrones has kind of destroyed the sort of... the life of the city because it's become this gigantic Game of Thrones theme park. And it does look... If you want to find a medieval... If you went to Dubrovnik out of season it is probably as good a glimpse of a kind of medieval walled city as you'll ever see
which has been utterly ruined by mass tourism. And actually, Game of Thrones has kind of destroyed the sort of... the life of the city because it's become this gigantic Game of Thrones theme park. And it does look... If you want to find a medieval... If you went to Dubrovnik out of season it is probably as good a glimpse of a kind of medieval walled city as you'll ever see|||
but not in summer when it's full of Game of Thrones fans posing for pictures on Iron Thrones um what about Hadrian's Wall Spike Searle asked a question about Hadrian's Wall didn't Martin get the point of Hadrian's Wall completely wrong it was never meant as an impenetrable barrier, perhaps a linear forward operating base and or a customs border. Tom, you must have very strong views about Hadrian's Wall.
but not in summer when it's full of Game of Thrones fans posing for pictures on Iron Thrones um what about Hadrian's Wall Spike Searle asked a question about Hadrian's Wall didn't Martin get the point of Hadrian's Wall completely wrong it was never meant as an impenetrable barrier, perhaps a linear forward operating base and or a customs border. Tom, you must have very strong views about Hadrian's Wall.|||
We talked about that in our episode on walls. Yes. So we won't go into that. I mean, I think that the role that Hadrian's Wall plays in the imagination as a kind of outer limit
We talked about that in our episode on walls. Yes. So we won't go into that. I mean, I think that the role that Hadrian's Wall plays in the imagination as a kind of outer limit|||
of civilization. That's the kick. And that is something that, you know, it's there in Kipling's poetry. Again, that is a perspective. That kind of,
of civilization. That's the kick. And that is something that, you know, it's there in Kipling's poetry. Again, that is a perspective. That kind of,|||
yeah. Yeah. It's mediated. This is a conception that is mediated through earlier interpretations of history recreations of history literary reworkings of history um and i think that's you know that's that's the kind of that that adds resonance to the portrayal of history in game of thrones but also he has martin does this not quite nice thing where he has they they call the people beyond the wall the wildlings don't they and actually in it had the game of thrones been written 100 years earlier you would never see
yeah. Yeah. It's mediated. This is a conception that is mediated through earlier interpretations of history recreations of history literary reworkings of history um and i think that's you know that's that's the kind of that that adds resonance to the portrayal of history in game of thrones but also he has martin does this not quite nice thing where he has they they call the people beyond the wall the wildlings don't they and actually in it had the game of thrones been written 100 years earlier you would never see|||
the wildlings as people you would only ever see them as sort of frightening sort of figures but in game of thrones you they are humanized and you are one of the characters goes out north and sort of joins them and you you sort of end up they call themselves the free folk they're kind of almost like cossacks or something i'm not not sure about that because the parallel for Kipling and for imperial writers was with the Northwest Frontier. Yeah. So they would imagine Roman soldiers in Northern Britain as being analogous to British soldiers on the frontier of British India.
the wildlings as people you would only ever see them as sort of frightening sort of figures but in game of thrones you they are humanized and you are one of the characters goes out north and sort of joins them and you you sort of end up they call themselves the free folk they're kind of almost like cossacks or something i'm not not sure about that because the parallel for Kipling and for imperial writers was with the Northwest Frontier. Yeah. So they would imagine Roman soldiers in Northern Britain as being analogous to British soldiers on the frontier of British India.|||
But of course they were, you know, they were fascinated by what lay beyond, by Afghanistan. Well, the man who would be king. Yeah yes which is actually a very um a very george rr martin yeah that's a great story that would be a brilliant podcast actually on kipling and all that sort of stuff anyway we're just talking about future podcasts instead of doing our own one uh fordek has a question which i like a lot game of thrones is usually compared with the wars of the roses but to me absolutely screams of the Wars of the Diadochi. Diadochi.
But of course they were, you know, they were fascinated by what lay beyond, by Afghanistan. Well, the man who would be king. Yeah yes which is actually a very um a very george rr martin yeah that's a great story that would be a brilliant podcast actually on kipling and all that sort of stuff anyway we're just talking about future podcasts instead of doing our own one uh fordek has a question which i like a lot game of thrones is usually compared with the wars of the roses but to me absolutely screams of the Wars of the Diadochi. Diadochi.|||
I don't know how to pronounce that, actually. I don't know its name. Diadochi. Diadochi. Now, that would make a series. I agree. So the Diadochi are Alexander's successors, the successors of Alexander the Great.
I don't know how to pronounce that, actually. I don't know its name. Diadochi. Diadochi. Now, that would make a series. I agree. So the Diadochi are Alexander's successors, the successors of Alexander the Great.|||
And I actually have a fantasy. I don't know. Four Deck must have a window into my mind. I have a secret fantasy that one day I'll be reincarnated as a showrunner for HBO. And this is the series I would make. Two series on Alexander the Great,
And I actually have a fantasy. I don't know. Four Deck must have a window into my mind. I have a secret fantasy that one day I'll be reincarnated as a showrunner for HBO. And this is the series I would make. Two series on Alexander the Great,|||
and then I'd go through his successors and end with Cleopatra. How many series would you have? 12, 10. But no dragons? No, but pyramids. You'd have a lot in Egypt. You'd have the Seleuc pyramids. You'd have a lot in Egypt. You'd have the Seleucid Empire.
and then I'd go through his successors and end with Cleopatra. How many series would you have? 12, 10. But no dragons? No, but pyramids. You'd have a lot in Egypt. You'd have the Seleuc pyramids. You'd have a lot in Egypt. You'd have the Seleucid Empire.|||
You'd have the Greco-Bactrian Kingdom. You'd have stuff going on in Thrace. You'd bring in the Romans. Come on, Tom. Would you like to be a consultant? Yeah. For the Roman episodes. Great.
You'd have the Greco-Bactrian Kingdom. You'd have stuff going on in Thrace. You'd bring in the Romans. Come on, Tom. Would you like to be a consultant? Yeah. For the Roman episodes. Great.|||
You're in the money. Here's one from Chet Archbold. Friend of the day. It's not a podcast episode without's one from chet archbold a friend of the day it's it's not a it's not a podcast episode without a question from chet um game of thrones seems to me like the middle ages by ways of nietzsche were actual medieval nobles as brutal nihilistic and utterly fixated on power generally speaking as the fictional ones well this is me yeah this is me this is why chet is great yes chet i agree with you we've already done that one okay i think
You're in the money. Here's one from Chet Archbold. Friend of the day. It's not a podcast episode without's one from chet archbold a friend of the day it's it's not a it's not a podcast episode without a question from chet um game of thrones seems to me like the middle ages by ways of nietzsche were actual medieval nobles as brutal nihilistic and utterly fixated on power generally speaking as the fictional ones well this is me yeah this is me this is why chet is great yes chet i agree with you we've already done that one okay i think|||
what about warwick the kingmaker warwick the kingmaker was very brutal nihilistic fixated on he wasn't nihilistic well i mean he i suppose he wasn't nihilistic but he was fixated on power and brutal i mean he is a game of thrones character richard neville earl of warwick i used to love him when i was a child he was my favorite medieval character and of course richard richard iii as portrayed by by shakespeare's yes or um or laurence olivier yeah but the whole point is that that's an exaggeration isn't it yes i suppose so i suppose so what about um have we got time for one more you think well here's a good question to end on. Yeah. Johnny Wilson. I don't think that's the same as Jonathan Wilson,
what about warwick the kingmaker warwick the kingmaker was very brutal nihilistic fixated on he wasn't nihilistic well i mean he i suppose he wasn't nihilistic but he was fixated on power and brutal i mean he is a game of thrones character richard neville earl of warwick i used to love him when i was a child he was my favorite medieval character and of course richard richard iii as portrayed by by shakespeare's yes or um or laurence olivier yeah but the whole point is that that's an exaggeration isn't it yes i suppose so i suppose so what about um have we got time for one more you think well here's a good question to end on. Yeah. Johnny Wilson. I don't think that's the same as Jonathan Wilson,|||
our former guest. I don't see him as a man who's going to be sending in questions about Game of Thrones. Jonathan Wilson, very, very stark character. Well, he's very Northern. I think the North... Is Dan Jackson. I think...
our former guest. I don't see him as a man who's going to be sending in questions about Game of Thrones. Jonathan Wilson, very, very stark character. Well, he's very Northern. I think the North... Is Dan Jackson. I think...|||
We can divide our guests up into Starks and Lannisters. Who are Lannisters? I'm not getting into that um yeah paul lay uh who having on um later this week to talk about uh gromar he's a sort of he's a stark isn't he he's uh yeah i mean from the southern reaches of i listen dominic we're spiraling off here we are okay johnny wilson got any thrones? Do you have a favourite throne? You must have a favourite throne. The peacock throne. Iran, the Shah.
We can divide our guests up into Starks and Lannisters. Who are Lannisters? I'm not getting into that um yeah paul lay uh who having on um later this week to talk about uh gromar he's a sort of he's a stark isn't he he's uh yeah i mean from the southern reaches of i listen dominic we're spiraling off here we are okay johnny wilson got any thrones? Do you have a favourite throne? You must have a favourite throne. The peacock throne. Iran, the Shah.|||
Yeah. Very good. Why? It's peacock. That's not a good reason in my view. It is. My favourite throne is the... Well, I've sat on the Iron Throne in Dubrovnik. So that's probably my...
Yeah. Very good. Why? It's peacock. That's not a good reason in my view. It is. My favourite throne is the... Well, I've sat on the Iron Throne in Dubrovnik. So that's probably my...|||
So your favourite throne is a made-up throne? It was plastic, actually. And you're sneering at me for choosing an actual throne. Yeah. Well, at least I sat on my throne. With peacocks. I've chosen a Disney-type throne, which is, of course, what my listeners would expect
So your favourite throne is a made-up throne? It was plastic, actually. And you're sneering at me for choosing an actual throne. Yeah. Well, at least I sat on my throne. With peacocks. I've chosen a Disney-type throne, which is, of course, what my listeners would expect|||
as a man of the people. I thought the Iron Throne was in Belfast. I think the truth is there were probably multiple Iron Thrones, and I may well have paid good money i may well have paid good money to a croatian um entrepreneur to sit on a fake iron throne which i think it's a nice epitaph for my entire life there was a photo of the queen looking at on the iron throne no looking at it all right i think it should be i can't believe she didn't sit in it i mean she's so she's done prince philip would have been straight on it um yeah prince harry well prince harry is a very
as a man of the people. I thought the Iron Throne was in Belfast. I think the truth is there were probably multiple Iron Thrones, and I may well have paid good money i may well have paid good money to a croatian um entrepreneur to sit on a fake iron throne which i think it's a nice epitaph for my entire life there was a photo of the queen looking at on the iron throne no looking at it all right i think it should be i can't believe she didn't sit in it i mean she's so she's done prince philip would have been straight on it um yeah prince harry well prince harry is a very|||
game of thrones character yeah isn't he i mean he i think he he definitely ends up dead in game of thrones doesn't he doesn't win does he yeah what about william i think william might survive i think william would come through yeah i don't know you die at the end of season two who would win oh princess beatrice or somebody prince edward prince edward's my favorite member of the royal family why do you know why? His acting or his theatrical career with Andrew Lloyd Webber? No, I went to a service to commemorate the anniversary of the death of Athelflad, Lady of the Mercians in Tamworth. That's exactly the kind of thing you would do. Yeah, it was great.
game of thrones character yeah isn't he i mean he i think he he definitely ends up dead in game of thrones doesn't he doesn't win does he yeah what about william i think william might survive i think william would come through yeah i don't know you die at the end of season two who would win oh princess beatrice or somebody prince edward prince edward's my favorite member of the royal family why do you know why? His acting or his theatrical career with Andrew Lloyd Webber? No, I went to a service to commemorate the anniversary of the death of Athelflad, Lady of the Mercians in Tamworth. That's exactly the kind of thing you would do. Yeah, it was great.|||
There was the local fyrd had arrived in chain mail. There was the Mercian regiment with the regimental sheep. Regimental sheep, wow. I think there were 12 bishops. It was a fantastic occasion. And after it, we went to the castle in Tamworth. Prince Edward was there. And he said he was a big fan of Rubicon.
Oh, my God. So up to that point, I'd had no time for the man. But now... That is galling well i hope he becomes king i happen to know prince andrew is a very big fan of my book state of emergency about the ted heath years you don't want prince andrew though do you so i've become i've become prince edward's banner man yeah wow and i am willing to do what it takes but you see you've given the game onto the iron throne him onto the Iron Throne. When the Super Bowl breaks out, I will know where you stand,
天哪。所以在那之前，我根本没时间理这个人。但现在……这太厚颜无耻了，好吧，我希望他能成为国王，我碰巧知道安德鲁王子非常喜欢我关于希思执政时期的书《紧急状态》，你可不想让安德鲁王子当国王吧？所以我成了爱德华王子的支持者，是的，哇，我愿意为此付出一切，但你看，你已经把游戏引向了铁王座，让他坐上铁王座。当超级碗爆发时，我就会知道你的立场，
and I can use that against you. Well, you and Prince Andrew. That's anything to boast about. No, no, no, I might have to ditch him. Right, on that note, I think we should put the podcast to an end, because we've completely lost track of the questions, the subject, our audience, and, and yeah life itself so we will be back won't we with paul a talking about all of the cromwell the protectorate um british experiment with republicanism i think we'll keep that one more on track probably than
我就可以用这个来对付你。好吧，你和安德鲁王子。这有什么好吹嘘的。不，不，不，我可能得甩了他。好吧，就冲这一点，我觉得我们应该结束这期播客了，因为我们已经完全偏离了问题、主题、我们的听众，还有，还有生活本身，所以我们会回来的，对吧，和保罗·A一起聊聊克伦威尔、护国公时期，嗯，英国的共和主义试验，我想我们会比这次把这一期保持得更有条理一些，
than we did and then in the future for people who like Game of Thrones, gods, all that sort of stuff, the World Cup of Ancient Gods is looming. That's massive, isn't it? We're going to be advertising that somewhere. It's bigger than the Euros. I think it's much bigger than the Euros. Well, it hasn't been postponed, unlike the Euros, so we can actually deliver it on time and on schedule.
可能比……然后对于喜欢《权力的游戏》、神明等等之类的人来说，未来的“古代神明世界杯”即将到来。这太重磅了，不是吗？我们会在某处宣传那个。这比欧洲杯还要盛大。我觉得比欧洲杯宏大得多。嗯，它没有像欧洲杯那样被推迟，所以我们实际上可以按时按计划推出它。
And everybody can go. There's no restrictions on it. It'll be on Twitter. All are welcome. Please vote. If you have a favourite ancient god. Let's hope they've made it to the last 16. Huge excitement. There's a massive... I think we've had enough. It's the end
每个人都可以去。没有任何限制。它将会在推特上发布。欢迎所有人。请投票。如果你有最喜欢的古代神明。希望他们能进入前16强。无比兴奋。有一个巨大的……我觉得我们已经聊够了。这就是《权力的游戏》的结尾。
of Game of Thrones. ... ... ... ... ... ...... Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
…… …… …… …… …… …… 再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。
For bonus episodes, early access access ad-free listening and access There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告体验以及……本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。